women are not making it a time women
have their voices heard they transform
the entire world if women were
presidents all over the world the world
would be a safer place it would be a
home peaceful place
it would be a place of equality the
world would be a better world
two years after Hillary Clinton failed
to shatter the highest hardest glass
ceiling Americans elected a record
number of women to office in 2018 women
like me are supposed to run for office
but women make up only 24% of all
national parliaments and only six point
three percent of the total number of
international leaders men still ruled
the world it matters for women to be
fully represented in the leadership of
the world Ellen Johnson Sirleaf would
know she was elected Africa's first
female president in 2005 and put Liberia
back on his feet
after 14 years of brutal civil war
it was a huge grassroots action led by
Liberian women that paved mrs. Solis way
to power women film male domination in
our country had been there for too long
and was time for change they voted and
they voted and mass 80 percent of women
at the polls voted for ma Ellen as she's
known but today only twelve point three
percent of seats in the Liberian
parliament are held by women through
collaborative effort we have to break
down the barriers one by one and this is
how mrs. Sirleaf believes it could be
done I always say that women bring to
leadership a special sensitivity we need
to change a stereotype that women are
weak either way I woman who is able to
negotiate to compromise the final
Trinities is an example of strength
that's when you show that people are
given a dignity and the rights that they
deserve
one needs to look at constitutional
change that includes affirmative action
such as quarters even though you may
face them out over time because women
have been neglected over the whole
history of nations now is the time for
preferential treatment for them the
obstacles go beyond misogynistic and
caps their institutional institutions
are still dominated by men we must make
our institutions all over the world and
particularly in Africa stronger than the
individual so that the individual does
not use discretion to dictate the
participation of women in 2018 after two
terms in office
mrs. surly bucked the trend of African
presidents for life and stood down for
Liberia's first peaceful transfer of
power since the 1940s
I don't think given the state of our
country that a man would have gone to
the step cited only a woman could have
done it
one woman at the top can push harder but
unless you have enough women in the
system to get the support it can be a
very difficult job and I can use my own
example your no microscope all the time
I don't want to shock anyone I really
don't but the world is still run by men
we must put women in all levels right
across society no matter what area you
look at you see enough women
participating enough women being able to
move up enough women challenging the
status quo that's the Equality that we
search for and it's taking a while to
get it but it's coming and no one can
stop it this is an irreversible road
you